we have this tweet here that I want you
all to see so we can talk about this is
from debate Society of Berkeley AI is
getting out of hand y'all got me excited
for nothing and there are several photos
AI generated of trump being arrested and
they're pretty good so the first one
we're showing is just a bunch of NYPD
cops holding Trump who looks Panic to
the next one is Trump apparently
resisting arrest as a bunch of COPS
stand around him and try to lock him up
the next one is that this is really
funny this is my favorite one Trump
running panicked as some cops aren't
even looking at him and are running
apparently the other direction so okay
and then the last one is Trump once
again resisting arrest as cops are you
know yelling and pinning him down and
this cop here he's got he's got a
strange little hand you can't really see
it but uh the reason why I think this is
significant
we talked about it before with the AI
stuff people started making fake posts
and uh and and deep fakes that Trump had
already been indicted that Trump was
being arrested and then they make photos
like this I saw a bunch of these going
around people were like you know Trump
surrenders and some weren't as crazy as
this
but these photos
they're going to be hard to tell if
they're real
at a glance so what happens in 5200
years when some kid is looking through
the archives and he sees photos and he's
like I don't know which one's the real
one
it's dangerous yeah it's very I mean
history is being erased I mean we just
said that it's unlikely that we'll get
this big cuffing moment of trump but
they don't need it if they can just fake
it right if the idea is that the media
which is dominant left wing in this
country wants a picture of trump and
handcuffs all they need to do is you
know run one on the evening news that's
been AI generated and then issue an
apology the next day it's already too
late at that point they've exposed this
fake photo what happens if someone
someone right now who's I say 60 years
old they're not on Twitter they're not
on the internet they have no idea and
they turn on the Tucker Carlson they
turn on the Fox News and they're sitting
there and Tucker is like it's all an
outrage none of this is real and he's
like yeah you tell him Tucker and then
he goes to the bar where he meets up
with his friends and his friends like he
puts his glass on says let me let me
show you this picture and then he holds
it up for everybody and they see a
photograph of trump being arrested and
they go
no what is this that wow and they
believe it because they don't know
what's going on this my point is there
are probably a lot of people who
genuinely believe Trump was arrested and
these photos may be real
I think it's like the Fulfillment of a
fantasy for a lot of people like they'll
believe the photos even when you can
tell that these are sort of not right
the lighting's not right that one guy's
got a bizarre hand but it's the
Fulfillment of this thing that they've
been rabidly jonesing for for what four
plus years at this point they want Trump
and handcuffs so badly that they are
willing to believe uh a completely fake
photo I I hope they arrest them all
those cops are the same cop if you look
at that picture they're all the same guy
no that's the cop that one that's what
they look like they really really look
similar and yeah you just racially
profiling New York City right you are no
I see that photo and I'm like that looks
like
every protest I've ever been to yeah but
what I'll say in a moment ago I I do
hope Trump gets arrested I really really
hope he does I hope I hope they go down
to Florida a bunch of a bunch of cops
around his house and they knock on his
door they get a warrant
Trump answers and they say Mr President
you're under arrest I hope it happens so
the facade of our democracy can finally
be over
because I tweeted that and you got all
these lefties laughing and being like do
and I'm like okay listen
when Barack Obama can murder a 16 year
old American citizen without charge or
trial and get nothing nothing not so
much as a bad word could be said about
him by any of you people
then you want to arrest Donald Trump
because he asked he said I'll give you
some money if you claim that we didn't
bang like that's the crime of the
century for which you are going to go
and arrest so I'm kidding about going to
assess and actually arresting him but I
hope the arrest happens I hope he shows
up and they say haha we got him now
because then we can stop pretending like
these people are anything other than
Psychopaths who are trying to steal
power a couple years ago when Steve
Bannon uh turned himself in cfbi because
of whatever charges they're bringing
against him he I mean it was kind of a
it wasn't the most monumentous moment
but I do remember it being sort of
powerful watching him say like I'm gonna
do this like we've got to keep fighting
whatever else going in and then like
obviously the legal battle continues but
it does have this moment where you feel
like
okay we've got to move forward like it
had it had weight behind it in some ways
I feel like Trump you know showing up
wherever being like I'm gonna turn
myself in I'm surrounding custody
because like we cannot keep going this
way and this is uh an abuse of power
like it will give him a platform in this
very powerful moment that yes obviously
I wish they wouldn't arrest him but on
the other hand like I don't think they
follow anything logical they're not
bound by the ethics that I think most
Americans are bound by and so we might
as well make the most of this thing like
that's why I was glad that he announced
like yes they're going to arrest me like
I'm telling you right now it's about to
happen like this is what our democracy
has come to it's sort of powerful it's
it's political theater in a way that I
wish we didn't have it on the other hand
I'm glad he's taking advantage of it
yeah I mean I guess it's a good thing
that he's he's going to well I mean it
it seems obvious that if he's going to
be arrested that he should capitalize on
it I mean if they're going to make these
moves he should do uh you know obviously
should do whatever he can he shouldn't
let them set the narrative yeah he
should he should he should definitely do
whatever he can to set the narrative and
having pictures of himself in handcuffs
or having his mug shot as a campaign ad
as the first president that's ever been
arrested by the opposing party when the
opposing party is in power you know like
and the I think that it's powerful I
think that it will matter to
to obviously to Mega people and we'll
get a far get them fired up and that
could make a difference in the polls but
it's still a long way away and we don't
know who else is going to be running and
stuff so I don't know that this matters
in 2024 it'll matter today and for the
next you know the news cycle probably
for a couple maybe a week or two but do
you feel like the left's Turning Trump
into a martyr with this action well
that's exactly what's happening they've
been the left is they've been going
after Trump now for decades it's just
that in the last four or six years about
your collusion all that's the
impeachment everything they're they're
concerned about Donald Trump and you
have to ask yourself you know if Donald
Trump truly lost the 2020 election why
are they going after him now right well
I mean if he truly lost the election why
are they going after him you would think
7 million volts right 2020 what do you
lose by seven million 71 million
decision it was like 10 or something
okay 11 million or maybe maybe you're
right maybe it was like seven or eight
okay but the point is he lost by several
million he lost the electors by 60 or
70. you would think you'd want the same
guy coming back in four years why don't
they want that man coming back why do
they because they have to paint him as a
as is like a criminal that this guy's
got to be put in jail putting handcuffs
because there's people afraid of them
because people saw Joe Biden
you could only get away with a Joe Biden
one time and they know it do you think
your mind's cut is he the nominee oh
yeah yeah he is I mean what are they
gonna do who are they going to get well
I I don't know maybe maybe Michelle
wants to jump in it but I'll tell you
something I'm sending you're buying 25
bucks
I
want Joe Biden to be the
so bad I hope that's who they have they
have a short batch I got it very very
limited I don't think it's a bench it's
like a chair well I want him to be the
nominee so bad because Donald Trump's
going to be the nominee he'll be the
47th president I agree yeah the when
you had that year a year is an eternity
in politics that doesn't matter what
Trump did in 17 18 and 19. all that
matters is that last year was coven and
there was no Sports there was no movies
everybody was pissed off and they sat in
the media and across the board Trump did
it
Joe Biden hit in his basement and people
went out and and you have to look at the
enthusiasm levels enthusiasm for Biden
was was was nil but enthusiasm
enthusiasm against Trump was almost as
high or higher than enthusiasm
enthusiasm for Trump among his base
here's the thing
we now have a Joe Biden the economy is
in shambles we're nearing World War III
all of the things Trump said that were
going to happen have happened or are
happening or about to happen
and regular people are wondering why it
cost six bucks for a dozen eggs
so you can't run the guy again because
all of these problems that have been
going on for years people ain't happy
about yeah do you think they're you
think they're going to run someone else
I'm saying they're going after Trump
desperately because they don't have a
candidate because who are they going to
run Kamala no like there's no obvious
alternative I mean Ojo Biden was
supposed to be the end of the Old Guard
welcoming in this new era and you know
Noah
that's their best I bet they would it's
the only thing they would have Ronda
Santos if they wanted basically Trump
enough I mean obviously they just give
up and they're alive well the only
person who can beat Trump they like
nominate Joe manchin because he's a
Democrat but like he's the best that
they can do
I mean yeah they were smart that's what
they do but again they set this
precedent of uh we are ending the old
party Democrat right like Pelosi's gone
Joe Biden I think is supposed to be the
last AOC old white president and they
never successfully cultivated a uh
someone to take over for him and he
doesn't want to leave office I mean the
reason Joe Biden hasn't announced is not
because he doesn't want to run it's
because the party doesn't want him to
can you imagine how amazing it would be
if they choose ocasio-cortez
just to see the AOC Trump debates uh
don't don't tease me like that don't
cheat that would be I'm just gonna get a
comment I'll see her tomorrow
uh it would be just beautiful I'm not
saying anything but I'm saying it'll be
a sight to behold do you mind you have
to do that
people are talking about Michelle Obama
uh today no yeah yeah yeah and I think
Michelle Obama could she could be one of
those she's going to do it for the good
of the country so to speak she'll be one
of those that says I really don't want
to and my husband doesn't want me to but
I have to for the good of the country
you could see her jump in that that
would be a little scary because I'm
concerned about the electorate and how
they vote but we did get some hope
though a couple weeks ago did we not
with with the crime that we're seeing
across the country get rid of that nut
job in Chicago that light foot oh you
see they're not just horrible do you see
the reporters say get the hell out of
this city no no right so maybe people
are maybe people in the cities in these
inner cities minority groups and others
are saying you know what uh our children
matter too crime matters and inner
cities now we've got a mayor that is
just you know the escape the thing about
Chicago is
it was all based on race
so if you look at the election map and
overlay it with the racial neighborhoods
demographics map it's it's the the top
the person who won the neighborhood was
the race of the people who lived in the
neighborhood that was probably the the
in my view the dominant Factor Lori
Lightfoot won
um uh in almost every black neighborhood
and then uh was it Dallas was that the
guy white dude won all the white
neighborhoods and then the Hispanic did
one of the Hispanic neighborhoods and
then in the college areas there was a
woke uh black man who won which is
unsurprising for woke people but it was
almost entirely based on race so I think
what ends up happening is white voters
mobilized due to the crime in their
areas and then voted based on not
necessarily race but principally I I I
should say principally but predominantly
and the reason I say not entirely is
because the woke white people voted for
for a black man but it was shocking to
see the racial breakdowns there thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time